the white house is smarter than you
think
the politicians are smarter than you
think
inflation is raging at the highest
levels we've seen in years
cpi officially is being reported at 5.4
percent that's the highest that cpi has
been in 13 years core inflation is
4.3
that is in june and july the highest in
30 years
now when you have high rates of
inflation four to five percent what that
means is you have to
increase the amount of money that you
are making by four to five percent
simply to keep up with inflation that is
the only way that you can protect your
purchasing power so if you work an
hourly job and you're getting paid 10 an
hour in 2019 in 2020 you're getting paid
10 an hour and then again this year
you're getting paid 10 an hour you're
actually getting paid less in purchasing
power terms than you were previously and
so you have to continue to get some sort
of raise to protect that purchasing
power well how big should the raise be
we've seen places like chipotle and
other types of fast food restaurants
raise prices three to four percent to
offset the raise and labor that they are
providing we've seen places like
blackrock investment banks raise base
pay for all people within their
organization by eight plus percent
but now we have seen that the house of
representatives your elected leader
are deciding that they are going to
raise the maximum annual salary for
their staff to 199
300
that's right the staff for the house of
representatives the maximum they can
make now is 700 below 200 grand that is
up from 173
900
so what that tells you is that the house
of representatives your elected leaders
the same people who are telling you
listen to the economist don't worry
about inflation this is transitory
have chosen to increase the pay of their
own staffers by about 14
chipotle you're an hourly worker you get
three or four percent raise you work at
an investment bank like a blackrock you
get eight percent but you work for the
government you get a 14 raise and so
what we are seeing is the classic don't
listen to what they're saying watch what
they're doing if they are willing to
give a 14
raise to their own staffers there is no
way in hell they think that inflation is
only four or five percent they're giving
a raise that is almost three times that
amount
and so don't listen to what they say
watch what they do
when we start to understand that now a
staffer could make 199
and 300
that means that there may be some
staffers who actually are getting paid
more than some of our elected leaders
what do i mean
well the compensation for most u.s
senators and representatives and
delegates
is around 174 thousand dollars so if a
staffer could get paid 199 000
and around
average compensation is 174 000 for some
of the elected leaders
literally staffers could be making more
than the people that you've chosen to
represent you
in the halls of congress or the senate
and so another sign that this is all
just nonsense and so we've got a letter
from nancy pelosi that we're going to
pull up here that basically explains why
they are doing this
now this is something that you have to
get very comfortable with as we move
forward in the future
there is all kinds of things out laid
here but what they
essentially say at the top is a key
priority for strengthening the congress
so that it can best serve the american
people is ensuring that our offices and
committees have access to the best
talent in america i agree with that we
should have the best people either as
our elected officials or working for our
elected officials
and so then immediately she says as
speaker i have been proud to take steps
to ensure a diversity of experience and
talent among staff
that sounds very smart so that the halls
of congress at every level truly reflect
those who are
we are honored to serve
makes sense
but to that end today it is my privilege
to announce an important new reform for
our institution raising the maximum
annual rate of pay of the staff this
order will help the congress recruit and
retain the outstanding and diverse
talent that we need as it also helps
ensure parity between employees of the
house of representatives
and other employees of the federal
government
time out
what
you can go work in the government and
make 200 grand
what the hell is going on in the
government
why is it that we can't balance a budget
but we're paying
staffers now up to 200 grand but other
employees in the government how many
employees in the government get paid 200
grand
what is going on
the letter continues
this important action follows steps
taken over the last two congress to make
the house more inclusive open and
representative of the full range of
voices and values of our communities
these steps include establishing the
house office of diversity and inclusion
and taking action to establish the
select committee on the modernization of
congress
they are so antiquated that they have a
select committee on the modernization of
congress
and they're paying people two hundred
thousand dollars as staffers
what is going on
the decision to raise the maximum annual
rate of pay was recommended by the chair
of the committee on the house
administration furthermore builds on the
work of the select committee on the
modernization of congress which under
the chairman has carefully reviewed and
held hearings on the issue in related
manner
they literally are having meetings about
meetings about meetings
about paying themselves more
nuts we should pay people
an adequate salary we should try to
incentivize the best people to do this
but this sounds a lot different than
when politicians say i'm not doing it
for the money i'm doing it because i
want to serve for the people i want to
represent the people in congress or in
the senate so which is it is it that
they're doing it for the money or
they're doing it because they feel
called to serve
you can't have both
and if you're going to increase the
salary by 14
don't throw in the diversity and
inclusion clauses and the kind of wave
of hand as if that just allows you to do
whatever you want because as long as you
say it's diversity and inclusion then
people will just say yep of course we
have to do it
just say what it is
you're raising salaries by 14
because you've voted to a tribute
and help devalue the currency at a
historic rate
inflation hasn't been this high
in 13 to 30 years depending on how you
count it
and if you're going to contribute to the
devaluation of the currency the only way
you can keep people is if you pay them
more but you could have paid them three
percent more five percent more but you
chose 14. why 14 because the official
inflation number is much higher than the
4 to 5 official numbers and everyone
knows it and so they're explicitly
admitting it here
joe and john what do we think in terms
of them now increasing the maximum pay
of staffers to 200 grand i don't have a
problem with 200 grand look i think that
uh like you said all the time right
incentives run everything so you want to
incentivize the best and the smartest
people that we have here to run for
important positions right and government
elected officials are certainly that
that determine the rules and laws and
the regulations of this country so i
think that when it comes to salary you
don't want to associate uh you know an
elected official with a lower income
than they should be able to get right so
you want to incentivize them with high
pay uh you know good incentives all this
kind of stuff the problem is the timing
right so when we talk about how
inflation's running hot how they've
contributed to that and how they're
saying everything will be fine it's
transitory there's no issues
we don't expect this to drive the
inequality gap higher or wider anything
it's a real weird timing-wise when they
come out and say hey look now we're
going to give ourselves 14 raises at the
same time that we're telling you
everything's going to be fine so
the bottom line is look the government's
not looking out for you they're not
going to tell you uh to go get the raise
yourself they're not going to get the
race for you what you have to do is look
out for yourself you have to go demand
or ask for a raise right if you're doing
a good job and lay out all the reasons
why that's important show them how your
purchasing power is being devalued show
them how you're doing a good job show
them why you deserve this extra money
but at the end of the day all the
government officials are doing are
inflating themselves right and uh and
making sure they're being paid relative
to the inflation in this country and
demanding that their purchasing power
stays at an adequate level or increases
actually so i think from an incentive
perspective the the number two hundred
000 doesn't really mean much to me right
like i don't have a problem with them
making that amount of money i think uh
in a world where we want to incentivize
people to do that job that makes sense
that's a fine amount but when it comes
to giving yourself a raise when you're
telling everyone else inflation's not a
problem it's transitory all this stuff
it's kind of weird
i actually think that they should just
pay everyone a million bucks then like
if you're gonna pay people a lot then
just go overboard like just literally
pay all the staffers a million dollars
make it hyper competitive literally
steal people from goldman sachs or
google or facebook or you know whatever
big organization just pay all the
staffers a million dollars get the best
people and just say that's what you're
doing yeah but it feels like that's not
what's happening john what do you think
the government is just like us
that's what it is
people are getting raises to fight
inflation right people realize that
they're being paid less the government's
doing the exact same thing just on a
higher level they're getting 14 other
people are getting eight we're also not
counting uh the the incentive of uh all
this this opportune trading that they're
doing in the stock market and all that
kind of stuff that counts for something
in the salary range or the compensation
range i think well the
what for sure that's definitely
happening i mean nancy pelosi is the
best options trader in america uh i
don't know how she does it but when you
got inside your info yeah well it's not
insider it's just i just know things
that you don't know because i'm smart
obviously uh i
don't even get me started on that uh and
by the way it's on both sides of the
aisle it's not just one uh
but the other piece of it
here i guess is like do we think the
raise is because it's about retaining
talent or recruiting talent or do you
think it's because of inflation
and retain the outstanding and diverse
talent that we need that's what they're
saying so the official line here is
we're giving the staffers a 14 raise on
the maximum amount that they can earn
only because we need to recruit and
retain great talent they don't mention a
single word about inflation about the
devaluation of the currency about
monetary or fiscal power their
performance just happened this year it
just happens to be that food
transportation housing everything else
is more expensive by 5 10 15 20 percent
in some cases so to like i said it's a
weird time that they're giving
themselves a 14 raise they could do this
any year right and i'm sure they've
tried in the past but when you uh see
inflation run as hot as we are and you
keep telling everyone don't worry don't
worry don't worry like you said watch
what they're doing they're giving
themselves a 14 raise in the same breath
that they're telling you not to be
concerned if the elected officials could
give themselves a 20 raise to themselves
like not their staffers the staffers
they would do that too right like that
that would happen automatically house
prices up 23 year-over-year wholesale
prices up 7.8
asset prices
up 46 annualized used cars 41
energy 23 cpi 5.4 percent they are
saying that is for retaining talent i
don't believe a word about it there is
nobody who is now all of a sudden going
to go get a job as a staffer because i
don't make 174 i make 199 000. a 20 000
difference at those levels does not
matter it does not matter whether i want
to go be a staffer or not the job still
sucks i still gotta wear a suit and tie
or heels on washington dc walk around
it's hot in the summer i still gotta
deal with the bureaucratic nonsense 20
grand isn't going to change whether
somebody wants to work there or not it's
all
nonsense hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com
so that you can get an account we can
get after it
you